[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta
Slomka guten Abend wir werden reagieren
hat US-Präsident Joe Biden in einer
ersten Reaktion angekündigt nun wartet
die Welt darauf wie diese Reaktion
ausfallen wird drei US-Soldaten wurden
ja gestern getötet rund drei Dutzend
verletzt einen solchen Verlust hat es
für die US-Armee seit Jahren nicht
gegeben lange Zeit hat die US-Regierung
auf die vielen Attacken gegen ihre
Truppen im Nahen Osten ja eher milde
reagiert dabei kamen diese Angriffe aus
allen Richtungen aus dem Jemen aus
Syrien und Irak von unterschiedlichen
Gruppen die aber eines gemeinsam haben
enge Kontakte nach Terra
dieser Schattenkrieg den Iran in der
ganzen Region führt könnte nun eine
gefährliche Eskalationsstufe erreicht
haben Benjamin Daniel
berichtet diese Satellitenaufnahmen
zeigen die Basis von oben in der drei
amerikanische Soldaten starben und
Dutzende verletzt wurden der
US-Präsident äußerte sich bisher nur
knapp am Rande einer Veranstaltung in
South
Carolina für uns war es gestern ein
harter Tag im Osten wir haben drei
mutige Soldaten bei einem Angriff auf
eine unserer Basen verloren wir werden
darauf
antworten bei der Basis handelte es sich
um den sogenannten Twer 22 an der
jordanischen Grenze zu Syrien die
Einrichtung wird hauptsächlich von
Truppen genutzt die an einer Beratungs
und unterstützungsmission für die
jordanischen Streitkräfte beteiligt sind
Joe Biden stellte klar dass hinter der
drohenattacke eine militante Gruppe
stehe die bereits seit Monaten
amerikanische Soldaten angreife und von
Iran unterstützt
werde wir suchen keinen Krieg mit Iran
und wollen nicht eskalieren es gibt eine
ganze Reihe an Optionen die der
Präsident sich anschauen wird aber ich
möchte ihm da nicht
vorgreifen auch die Frage warum die
Drohne nicht rechtzeitig abgeschossen
wurde wird untersucht eine weitere
Eskalation im Nahen Osten das will der
US-Präsident in jedem Fall verhindern
die klaren Worte mächtiger Republikaner
spielen ihm dabei nicht in die Karten
fordert Senator lindseay Graham bei Ex
die US-Regierung auf signifikante Ziele
im Iran anzugreifen Zitat greift Iran
jetzt an trefft sie hart dann schalten
wir noch nach Washington zu Claudia
Bates das das klingt ja so als stünde
Joe Biden bei der Wahl seiner
militärischen Mittel erheblich unter
innenpolitischen
Druck ja es wird hier von ihm erwartet
dass er sehr deutlich reagiert die
Republikaner lassen keine Chance aus
beiden als schwach zu charakterisieren
es gibt die Forderung von Seiten der
Republikaner wir haben es gerade gehört
Iran selbst anzugreifen bisher hat Joe
Biden ja auf Angriffe auf us-einrichtung
in der Region relativ zurückhaltend
reagiert aber diesmal sind eben zum
ersten Mal US-Soldaten getötet worden
ein Senator sagte alles andere als eine
verheerende militärische Vergeltung
würde beiden als Feigling bestätigen
auch Donald Trump stimmt natürlich ein
sagt äh dass nur er den dritten
Weltkrieg verhindern könne das heißt Joe
Biden muss so besonnen reagieren dass er
keine Eskalationen in der Region
riskiert aber gleichzeitig so stark dass
es hier in den USA als angemessen
wahrgenommen wird und das ist ein sehr
schmaler Grad auf dem er da geht das
klingt so ein bisschen nach der
Quadratur des
Kreises ja genau das ist das Dilemma
denn die usreierung will auf jeden Fall
einen größeren Krieg äh vermeiden
gleichzeitig hat beiden aber ja gesagt
die USA werden die Verantwortlichen zur
Rechenschaft ziehen und die Frage die
hier jetzt gestellt wird ist heißt das
denn dass es begrenzte Angriffe auf
Ziele direkt im Iran geben könnte auch
wenn Regierungsbeamte muss man sagen das
Gegenüber US-Medien als unwahrscheinlich
bezeichnet haben zunächst mal wird noch
genau analysiert was eigentlich die
Verwicklung von Iran war ob direkt von
dort der Befehl zu diesem Angriff kam
dann wird natürlich auch gesprochen mit
den anderen Ländern in der Region auch
versuchen die USA Israel und die
Palästinenser an den Verhandlungstisch
zu bringen also auf allen Kanälen wird
jetzt versucht die Temperatur
runterzubringen während gleichzeitig
eben ein Militärschlag hier als zwingend
angesehen wird um ein deutliches Zeichen
an Iran zu senden Angriffe auf
US-Truppen in der Region zu
unterlassen danke schön Claudia nach
Washington wie gesagt die nahöstliche
Gemenge ist gefährlich und für die
US-Regierung mehr als heikel die
jemenitischen huthis sind da nur ein
Teil des Problems in dieser
Problemzone mit ihren Attacken auf
Schiffe im Roten Meer haben sie
allerdings besondere Aufmerksamkeit
erregt und da geht es ja auch um globale
Handelswege weniger im Fokus der
Öffentlichkeit steht wie es im Jemen
zugeht wo die hthies erhebliche Teile
unter ihre Kontrolle gebracht haben
einschließig der Hauptstadt Sana unsere
Reporterin gline atai war gerade zwei
Wochen im Jemen im Herrschaftsgebiet der
husis sie reden wie Erwachsene wenn man
sie nach dem Krieg fragt Schüler im
Herrschaftsgebiet der huti Rebellen
erzählen wie sie über ausländische
Besucher
denken ausländer können kommen es ist
sicher hier aber wenn sie aus Ländern
kommen die Israel unterstützen wie
Deutschland oder Frankreich dann töten
wir sie alles
klar
Indoktrination der jüngsten gehört zu
den Grundlagen der H Herrschaft
unzählige Poster preisen ihre getöteten
Krieger die oft noch wie Kinder Aussehen
über allem tront eine Lichtgestalt
Revolutionsführer abdelmak al seine
Familie ist qua Abstammung allen
Jemeniten überlegen sie führt einen
theokratischen Polizeistaat an in dem
viele vor unserer Kamera extreme Angst
haben etwas zu
sagen vor der Küste Jemens haben seine
Rebellen erneut ein Schiff angegriffen
solollche Bilder und die von gekarperten
Frachtern das ist der neue Krieg auf den
die huis die Jemeniten eingeschworen
haben wir warnen jeden in Europa sich an
die Seite der USA zu stellen und uns
anzugreifen wer das macht der bedroht
sich selbst wir können Jahrzehnte
kämpfen und auf alle Schiffe Zielen die
uns angreifen
und natürlich griffen sie ja nur an um
einen Waffenstillstand für die Kinder in
Gaza zu
erzwingen aber was ist mit den Kindern
auf der anderen Seite der
bürgerkriegsfront die vom Häuserkampf
gezeichnete Millionenstadt t wird seit
Jahren von his belagert Einwohner
erzählen wie H Scharfschützen immer noch
auf Zivilisten schieß so wie auf abah
Jahre die scha als er den Schmerz spürte
seine rechte Hand wurde nach fünf
Operationen gerettet aber er kann sie
nicht mehr
bewegen die hosis haben kein Haus hier
ohne einen verletzten ohne einen
getöteten zurückgelassen es gibt kein
Haus ohne Leid sie verletzen die
Waffenruhe sie schießen immer noch auf
Kinder bombardieren
Wohnhäuser und die his blockieren die
Wasserzufuhr fast alle Einwohner von
sind auf gespendete wassertrucks
angewiesen die his haben uns so viel
Leid gebracht wir haben kaum Gas kaum
Wasser alles wegen Ihnen all diese
Kriege hier sind ihre
Schuld die Belagerung von T sei eine
kollektive Bestrafung ein mögliches
Kriegsverbrechen der his sagen
Menschenrechtler und die Eskalation im
Roten Meer könnte das Leben der
Zivilisten hier noch weiter
schlimmen aus Sicht der Husi haben sie
immerhin geschafft von turnschur
Rebellen zu einer ernstzunehmenden
Kriegspartei zu werden die den
Weltsicherheitsrat der Vereinten
Nationen beschäftigt die UNO spielte den
Konflikten des Nahen Ostens derzeit
allerdings selbst keine glückliche Rolle
der Sicherheitsrat ist wie zu Zeiten des
Kalten Krieges komplett blockiert und im
israelisch-palästinensischen Konflikt
nimmt Israel die UNO schon lange als
einseitig war auch den UN
Generalsekretär der theoretisch die
Rolle eines neutralen Dritten spielen
könnte der aktuelle Amtsinhaber guteres
muss jetzt außerdem noch erklären was es
mit seiner un Hilfsorganisation im
Gazastreifen auf sich hat die Vorwürfe
reichen von Korruption und
hamasunterstützung bis hin zur direkten
Beteiligung an Massakern und
geiselmärmen Dara hasassan sad berichtet
ein Flüchtlingslager in Gaza das die
Hilfsorganisation unfra betreibt der
Organisation haben die wichtigsten
Unterstützer darunter die USA und
Deutschland die Gelder gestrichen zu
ihrem alltäglichen Leid kommt bei den
Flüchtlingen die Sorge auf dass sie auch
dieses wenige an Hilfe verlieren
könnten wir brauchen die Unterstützung
der unfi in diesen schwierigen Zeiten
wir brauchen essen sanitrestü Medik ohne
sie können wir nicht
überleben doch die Vorwürfe gegen un
Mitarbeiter wiegen schwer laut
israelisem Geheimdienst habe ein
Mitarbeiter Munition für den
Terroranschlag der Hamas organisiert ein
anderer bei der Entführung einer
Israelin mitgewirkt getant unter dem
Deckmantel humanitärer
Hilfe jetzt ist dasß voll ich haben 12
Mitarbeiter sich an diesem hamasterror
Terror beteiligt das ist eine ganz ganz
schwere Bürde und ich kann nur alle
Verantwortlichen der Vereinten Nationen
dazu auffordern jetzt wirklich eine
grundlegende Reform an hauptunggliedern
vorzunehmen der Glaubwürdigkeitsverlust
ist immens unfrei ist eine Folge des
ersten palästinerkrieges der Niederlage
der Araber und Israels Staatsgründung
1948 die vereinten Nationen Gründen das
Hilfswerk ein Jahr später für die
palästinensischen Flüchtlinge aber seit
Jahren steht die Organisation in der
Kritik nicht nur aus Israel ich kann nur
eins sagen wir haben ja immer wieder mit
dem unrchef auch mit cha humanitäre
Hilfe direkten Kontakten den letzten
Wochen und Monaten gehabt die
Einseitigkeit mit der hier gearbeitet
wird gegen Israel die ist wirklich
entsetzlich und die Bundesregierung muss
endlich handeln und darf nicht nur über
Pressemitteilung verkünden dass sie
zukünftige Projekte stoppt sondern
braucht ein Handeln jetzt im vergangenen
Haushaltsjahr hatte allein Deutschland
83 Millionen Euro an die
Hilfsorganisation überwiesen Geld was
den Menschen in Gaza in Zukunft fehlen
könnte mit dem Krieg zwischen der Hamas
und Israel geht es jetzt auch in den
Nachrichten erst noch mal weiter Heinz
in Tel Aviv gab es heute zum ersten Mal
seit Wochen wieder raketenalarm rund ein
Dutzend Raketen wurden nach
Medienberichten aus dem Gazastreifen auf
Israel abgeschossen die Hamas
reklamierte die Angriffe auf Tel Aviv
für sich in den ersten Wochen nach
Beginn des Krieges vor fast vier Monaten
waren der Süden und das Zentrum Israels
nah zu täglichem Raketenbeschuss durch
die Hamas
ausgesetzt in Frankreich demonstrieren
Landwirte weiter für bessere Arbeits und
Lebensbedingungen bei ihrem Protest
haben Bauern jetzt begonnen vor Paris
wichtige Zufahrtsstraßen zu blockieren
die Polizei mobilisierte ein groß
Aufgebot um einen Stillstand in der
Hauptstadt zu verhindern die bisher von
Premierminister Atal zugesagten
Erleichterungen gehen den Landwirten
nicht weit genug ein Gericht in Hongkong
hat die Abwicklung des hochverschuldeten
chinesischen immobilienkonzerns
evergrand angeordnet geklagt hatten
Gläubiger weil das Unternehmen immer
wieder Zahlungen verpasste
evergrand war Ende 2021 mit der
Begleichung seiner Auslandsschulden in
Verzug geraten und zum Symbol der
Schuldenkrise im chinesischen
Immobiliensektor geworden mit
umgerechnet über 300 Milliarden
US-Dollar ist der Konzern das am
höchsten verschuldete
Immobilienunternehmen
weltweit die elf Stahl prododuzierenden
Bundesländer machen Druck auf die
Bundesregierung sie fordern eine
Strategie zum Bau wasserstofffähiger
Gaskraftwerke um künftig weiter
heimischen Stahl herstellen und
wettbewerbsfähig bleiben zu können beim
Treffen der sogenannten Stahl Allianz
sagte Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck
eine geplante Strategie sei
entscheidungsreif und er hoffe auf
baldigen Konsens innerhalb der
Bundesregierung die neuen Kraftwerke
würden in den kommenden Jahren
übergangsweise mit Gas betetrieben und
dann Schritt für Schritt auf grünen
Wasserstoff
umgestellt Bundespräsident Steinmeier
hat zu einem breiten Bündnis für
Demokratie und gegen Extremismus
aufgerufen Steinmeier traf dazu heute
auch Vertreter von Wirtschaft sverbänden
Gewerkschaften sowie Unternehmen und
Betriebsräten er sagte wenn unsere
Demokratie angegriffen werde dann müsse
die demokratische Mitte die große
Mehrheit unserer Gesellschaft Position
beziehen und tatsächlich treibt das
Thema ja derzeit immer wieder
hunderttausende auf die Straße was zeigt
wie weit verbreitet inzwischen die Sorge
ist dass diese Demokratie verletzlicher
sein könnte als man es vielleicht
wahrhen will dazu mögen neben der
deutschen Geschichte auch Erfahrungen
beitragen die andere Staaten in jüngerer
Zeit gemacht haben und die zumindest
nicht dazu angetan sind zu glauben
Extremisten würden sich entzaubern wenn
sie erstmal an die Schalthebel der Macht
kommen im Gegenteil wie solche Kräfte
mit demokratischen Mitteln die
Demokratie aushöhlen könnten beschäftigt
auch Verfassungsrechtler mehr dazu von
Jan Henrich und
annkatrineske die Demokratie umbauen
Vikor Orban hat es in Ungarn getan
Wahlsystem Justiz Medienlandschaft seine
Macht hat er damit zementiert wäre das
auch in Deutschland möglich das
Vertrauen in die Verfassung ist hier
zulande groß eine Gruppe Juristen des
online portals verfassungsblog.de
forscht daran wie gerechtfertigt dieses
Vertrauen ist im thüringenprjekt
beleuchten sie verschiedene Szenarien
das Entscheidende an autoritären
Populisten wie wir sie heute erleben ist
eben dass sie formal legalistisch
vorgehen bedeutet sie gehen vor ohne die
Verfassung oder Gesetze offen zu brechen
und ähm müssen im Zweifel eben nicht mal
einen Buchstaben an Verfassung oder
Gesetzen ändern um ihre Ziele zu
erreichen Entwicklung aus anderen
Ländern hätten den Juristen gezeigt wo
eine extremistische Partei ansetzen
könnte Beispiel die Justiz als
allererstes würde sie wahrscheinlich die
ähm Gerichte angreifen und als Akteur
neutralisieren das bedeutet ähm vor
allem dass sie unliebsame Richter
entfernen und versuchen würde die
Gerichte mit eigenen Leuten zu besetzen
die Mütter und Väter des Grundgesetzes
hatten etliche Sicherungsmechanismen in
die Verfassung eingebaut vom begrenzten
Einfluss des Bundespräsidenten bis hin
zur Aufteilung der Gesetzgebung auf Bund
und Länder und doch bleiben mögliche
Schwachstellen eine davon ausgerechnet
beim Bundesverfassungsgericht selbst
dessen Rolle ist zw im Grundgesetz
festgeschrieben die Zusammensetzung
ließe sich jedoch mit einem einfach
esetz ändern so könnte der Bundestag
beispielsweise mit einer einfachen
Mehrheit das Prozedere zur Richterwahl
ändern oder das Gericht erweitern um
neue Positionen auf einenchlag mit
eigenen Leuten zu besetzen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht würde als
Kontrollinstanz faktisch lahmgelegt
Vorschläge das Gericht vor solcheneng
Gefahren abzusichern gibt es doch der
ehemalige Verfassungsrichter Peter Huber
ist skeptisch das was diskutiert wird
ist dass man das zweiittel
mehrheitserfordernis das heute im
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz steht in
das Grundgesetz reinschreibt aber es
gibt eben auch Gründe die das für die
vielleicht für nicht so tunlich
erscheinen lassen vor allem dann wenn
extremistische Kräfte zusammen mehr als
ein Drittel der Abgeordneten stellen
weil dann könnten sie die Wahl der
Verfassungsrichter blockieren
hundertprozentig sicher ließe sich das
Grundgesetz ohnehin nicht gestalten nein
das geht natürlich nicht der Staat lebt
davon dass wir uns für den Staat
einsetzen die Bürger müssen schon diese
Verfassung tragen und mit Leben füllen
die Demokratie kann sich wehren die
Verfassung ihr bestes Mittel dazu trotz
einiger
Schwachstellen dem Ansehen der
Demokratie hilft es natürlich nicht wenn
Korruptionsskandale rund um gewählte
Politiker bekannt werden immerhin wurden
sie aufgedeckt anders als den Diktaturen
in denen die Korruption ja fester
Bestandteil des Systems ist und von ganz
oben gesteuert wird wer da aufklären
will lebt gefährlich und unabhängige
Ermittler und Gerichte gibt es eh nicht
trotz solcher Vergleiche Skandale wie
der Qatar Bestechungsskandal im
EU-Parlament oder die aserbaidchan
Affäre um deutsche
Bundestagsabgeordnete schaden dem Image
der
Parlamente im aserbeidschans Skandal hat
die Münchner generalstaats waltschaft
heute Anklagen erhoben darüber berichtet
Alexander
Pool von hier kam mutmaßlich das
Schmiergeld Baku die Hauptstadt
Aserbaidschans
vorzeigemetropole des autokratischen
Herrschers Ilham aliev er und seine
Familie gelten als korrupt das Regime
betreibt imageepflege mit Formel 1
Rennen oder dem Eurovision Song Contest
offenbar wurde auch mit viel Geld
nachgeholfen alles in allem sollen wohl
Millionen an Politiker und Listen
geflossen sein im Rahmen dermittlungen
sind natürlich zahlreiche Durchsuchungen
durchgeführt worden auch im Ausland im
Wege der Rechtshilfe und Unterlagen
Schriftsätze und Datenträger umfangreich
sichergestellt worden eine Spur führt
direkt zu ihm Eduard Lindner ehemaliger
CSU
Bundestagsabgeordneter für die
Staatsanwaltschaft geht er als
Drahtzieher der Aserbaidschan Affäre
Lindner hat nicht nur offen Lobbyarbeit
betrieben und dafür ordentlich kassiert
er selbst soll andere Abgeordnete
bestochen haben wie etwa die
mittlerweile verstorbene cduptikerin
Karin strenz mit rund 150.000 € um in
der Folgezeit für Aserbeidschan tätig zu
werden um positiv abzustimmen und die
Interessen halt positiv zu gestalten
Eduard Lindner räumt auf Nachfrage ein
Geld über ausländische Briefkastenfirmen
aus Aserbaidschan bekommen zu haben aber
dass unser Handeln als Bestechung von
Abgeordneten eingestuft werden könnte
kam mir und meinen Mitwirkenden nie in
den
Sinn genau das aber Bestechung ist der
Vorwurf gegen einige Politiker etwa den
damaligen Bundestagsabgeordneten Axel
Fischer CDU wir gehen davon aus dass er
auch einmal positiv abgestimmt hat für
Aserbaidschan darüber hinaus geht's um
positive Redebeiträge
und auch um die Übermittlung von
geheimen Dokumenten ein Skandal der die
Glaubwürdigkeit in die Politik massiv
untergräbt für Sarah Schönewolf von
Abgeordneten watch kommt die Affäre für
Deutschland in einer schwierigen Zeit
weil es insgesamt die Glaubwürdigkeit in
Bundestagsabgeordnete einfach schmäert
und in das politische System insgesamt
also die Korruption die hier
stattgefunden hat ist einfach eine
andere Dimension als Verfehlung die wir
sonst gesehen haben weil sie insgesamt
die Glaubwürdigkeit des polilischen
Systems unterkräbt ob die Anklage der
Staatsanwaltschaft zugelassen wird muss
jetzt das Oberlandesgericht München
entscheiden wenn über die s bei der Bahn
berichtet wird oder über die Probleme
die es generell mit der Bahn gibt dann
steht ja meist der Personenverkehr im
Fokus der betrifft halt auch sehr viele
Menschen ganz unmittelbar in ihrem
Alltag auf den Güterverkehr richtet sich
weniger Aufmerksamkeit dabei ist der ja
auch ein wichtiger Verkehrsbereich und
Wirtschaftsfaktor s Rcken berichtet
Maschen liegt am südlichen Zipfel von
Hamburg der Rangierbahnhof dort ist der
größte Europas jeder zweite Container
aus dem Hamburger Hafen geht hier durch
normalerweise in den vergangenen Tagen
aber war es hier so ruhig wie noch nie
die Güterwagons kamen häppchenweise und
blieben stehen erst so langsam koppelt
sich der Rangierbahnhof wieder an die
Lieferketten an der Streik aber hat dem
Ruf der Bahn einen weiteren Dämpfer
verpasst bei unseren Kunden ist es
leider nach wie vor so dass der Umwelt
ganz ganz hinten steht und wichtig ist
der Preis wichtig ist die Flexibilität
und die bringt der LKW und wenn dann
jetzt auch noch die Bahn grundlegende
servicepre hat und das nenn ich nenne
das nichts anderes als ein serviceprem
was da jetzt gerade passiert dann haben
wir genau das Problem dass die
Rückverlagerung wieder im großen Maße
stattffindet den Zwang zur Schiene gibt
es nur bei Gefahrstoffen in der Chemie
oder bei schwerem Gepäck wie Eisenerz
oder Kohle der Rest ist
entscheidungssache der Disponenten die
Entscheidung lautet der LKW gewinnt mehr
als zwei Drittel aller Transporte
Deutschland sind straßensache die
Bundesregierung möchte die Schiene bis
2030 auf ein Viertel voranbringen ob das
klappt haben sie in der Hand die
Entscheider von morgen an der
logistikunie doch noch überlagern die
bahnprobleme von heute vieles selbst den
Streik man weiß der nächste Streik kommt
und es kommt zu nichts also die
Verhandlungen Läufen weiter und am
Ende eigt man sich dann doch wieder
nicht und dann plant man wieder mit dem
nächsten Streik man weiß aber nicht wann
und der man kann kein Vertrauen auf der
Basis aufbauen es ist halt auch
grundsätzlich ein Nachhaltigkeitsaspekt
überhaupt nicht der Weg in den wir gehen
wollen oder zu in die Richtung in die
wir gehen wollen dass wir wieder den
Rückschritt machen auf weiter auf die
schweren LKWs auf die hohen Emissionen
vom LKW aufzu auszuweichen auch die Bahn
befürchtet so ein Sprecher heute dass
die Wirtschaft viele Güter auf den LKW
zurückverlagert doch auch die vom Bund
beschlossene Grundsanierung der Schiene
kann keine Wunder bewirken es ist ein
bisschen wie wenn man eine Pflanze ganz
lange nicht gießt und plötzlich braucht
man sie aber und schmeißt ganz viel
Wasser drauf damit kann die Pflanze
natürlich auch nicht umgehen deswegen
ist fein und gut dass jetzt
die Mittel bereit stehen um das System
schiine ein bisschen zukunftsfähiger zu
machen aber es dauert natürlich eine
ganze Weile
bis dieses Geld überhaupt seine Wirkung
entfalten kann der Bahnstreik war ein
Unsicherheitsfaktor mehr für die
Logistiker so ist es auch nicht
verwunderlich dass der finanzielle
Schaden der vergangenen sechs Tage eher
überschaubar ist so mancher rechnet mit
einem deutlich höheren Ausfall durch die
treckerdemos heute die Landwirte in des
ziehen weiter die Probleme der Bahn
bleiben ja der gdlstik ist ja gerade
vorzeitig beendet worden aber an anderer
Stelle nah schon der nächste Streik
Heins ja die Gewerkschaft werdi hat im
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr in nahe
zu allen Bundesländern außer Bayern für
diesen Freitag zu Warnstreiks aufgerufen
zur Begründung hieß es die
Tarifverhandlungen sein ohne Ergebnis
geblieben jetzt seit der Punkt mehr
Druck auf die Arbeitgeber zu machen bei
den Forderungen von werdi geht es um
Einkommen und Arbeitsbedingungen mit
Unterschieden in den jeweiligen
Bundesländern und jetzt zur Börse mit
dem Blick auf die Wirtschaft Valerie
Haller eines der Topthemen heute ist die
KDW Group genau die KDW Group hat
Insolvenz in Eigenregie angemeldet diese
Form von Insolvenz die setzt nicht auf
Abwicklung sondern auf Sanierung und
tatsächlich liefen auch die Geschäfte
ganz gut in jüngster Zeit zur KDW group
gehört das gleichnamige Berliner
Luxuskaufhaus sowie das Alsterhaus in
Hamburg und der in München ansässige
Oberpollinger die drei Kaufhäuser
bleiben geöffnet die 1700 Mitarbeitenden
bekommen ihre Gehälter durch die Agentur
für Arbeit 3 Monate lang gezahlt als
Grund für die Insolvenz gibt die KDW
Group überhöhte Mieten an die
nachhaltiges Wirtschaften praktisch
unmöglich machen sollen in der
Pressemitteilung heißt es so sind die
Mieten im Vergleich zum Geschäftsjahr
2018 201 2019 um fast 37% gestiegen in
den nächsten Jahren sollen sie weiter
ansteigen mit der Insolvenz hofft die
KDW Group günstigere mieten aushandeln
zu können ob das gelingt ist allerdings
unklar die Immobilien der Kaufhäuser
gehören der signna Group des
österreichischen Investors Benko und der
hat ja gerade selbst Insolvenz
angemeldet Valerie Haller vielen
Dank die Zahl der gefälschten Banknoten
in Deutschland ist laut Bundesbank im
vergangenen Jahr deutlich gestiegen
polizeihandel und Banken zogen demnach
rund
56600 falsche Eurobanknoten aus dem
Verkehr das waren gut 28% mehr als ein
Jahr zuvor und auch weltweit ist die
Zahl der euroblüten gestiegen laut
Europäischer Zentralbank wurden 2023
insgesamt etwa 467 000 gefälschte
Euroscheine registriert ein Zuwachs von
rund 24
binnen
Jahresfrist in Berlin sind die Sterne
des Sports verliehen worden für ihr
gesellschaftliches Engagement wurden in
diesem Jahr 17 Sportvereine aus ganz
Deutschland geehrt der große Stern in
Gold ging an den Thüringer Lauf und
ausdauersportclub Eichsfeld er
überzeugte mit einer Initiative die
Blinden und seebehinderten Menschen
bundesweit hilft einen Guide zum
gemeinsamen Sporttreiben zu finden im
Rahmen der Preisverleihung betonte
Bundeskanzler Scholz den Wert des
breiten Sports für den
gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt das war's von uns es folgen
Wetter und montagskino und danach um 05
Uhr gibt's unser heute schnall Update
mit Gund da Gause morgen melden wir uns
dann in der Halbzeit beim DFB Pokal so
um 21:30 Uhr bis dahin vi
[Musik]
sehen
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter aus dem Südwesten
kommt die relativ milde Luft aber morgen
spielt noch etwas anderes eine Rolle
nämlich die Kaltfront hier die bringt
viele Wolken und relativ wenig Regen sie
ist also kaum wetterwirksam in der Nacht
gibt's nach Norden kompakte Wolken vor
allem nach Süden in klartes verbreitet
auf und dann bildet sich Nebel so
ähnlich ist das auch ganz im Westen
Deutschlands bei tiefsten Temperaturen
von -5 5° nach Bayern hin hier also
eisige Werte ganz anders im Nordwesten
6° z.B an der Nordsee und 7° am
niederrein deutlich milder und morgen
Vormittag im Süden erst einmal dichter
Nebel der löst sich dann auf und die
Sonne kommt hervor so ähnlich wie im
Osten Deutschlands oder hier am
Alpenrand aber sie sehen hier im
Nordwesten dichtere Wolken die
allmählich aufziehen und zum Nachmittag
bedeutet das dort beginnt es zu regnen
das zieht langsam in nach Deutschland
rein aber sie sehen hier meist sind es
kompakte Wolken Temperaturen dazu mit
Höchstwerten von 6° im Südosten
Deutschlands und das hier unter dem
Nebel deutlich kälter sein wird als ganz
im Westen mit 13° das ist für morgen
schon mal klar und 13° sind zu warm für
die Jahreszeit der Blick auf die
nächsten Tage am Mittwoch dann kompakte
Bewölkung und kaum Niederschlag bei 6
bis 13° am Donnerstag dann im Süden
deutlich dichter bewrkt mit bei 6 bis
12° und Freitag nach Nordosten hin mit
viel Wind und Regen bei ähnlichen
Temperaturen ein schönen
Abend